yeah what's up Samuel leaves here and
this is a message to all my young people
or maybe really old people maybe you're
a teenager and you've got a desire to
get into property maybe you're in your
20s you know what when I started out in
property I had a massive chip on my
shoulder
I was 17 years old I remember when I
went to my first networking event and I
felt like a kid in a suit completely out
of place I don't know anything about
property I don't know what a mortgage
was when the credit crunch came I
thought that the credit crunch was a new
cereal literally completely ignorant to
life completely ignorant to business yet
wanting to be a property investor
massive chip on my shoulder and I see
this all the time with young teenagers
getting into property sometimes like
fifteen sixteen and they're like can I
come to the crash course I'm a too young
let me teach them it unless you're so
young that you're like a crying baby
you're not too young to come to the
crash course you know or maybe people
are that 22 I mean when I was 21 I was
financially free had a lot of properties
but I still didn't have the confidence
to buy a property without a real adult
looking at it because in my mind I'm
still a kid when I'm negotiating
sometimes I try and bring someone along
with me who was a real adult because I
didn't think that estate agents even
took me seriously and it was really
weird when I got to an age where by like
I'd meet in the state agent and I was
older than them like I'm 20 to 23 and
they're 21 and I'm like wow I'm older
than them and they're an estate agent
and it was a massive hinderance to me it
was a massive problem having this big
chip on my shoulder
maybe you're real old I mean you might
be near like 70s or something thinking
people think I'm really old but I think
I get a lot of young people on my
youtube-channel paranoid about this
thing and it bothers them and they think
that people don't take them seriously
let me taste it what to help me and this
kind of got me through those times I
used to think you know what I never
liked Rihanna
when she made it she was like 18 she's
like a little bit older than me Wayne
Rooney just didn't Bieber Justin Bieber
over when he came out and he was like 14
and I think now we're about the same age
and I used to think if people pay those
young people who are younger than me or
my age millions and millions of pounds
for CDs and to play football or to do
whatever if you pay them millions of
pounds and they're younger than me maybe
maybe I'm valuable you know and I kind
of kept me going so at the moment like
when you see people from these bands
coming out and people are paying
millions of pounds to just go and meet
them and hear them sing and stuff it's
like what if people depend they're
millions of pounds because they can sing
well guess what
I can negotiate property deals guess
what I can support a good opportunity so
regardless of your age it doesn't matter
how old you all what matters is how much
value you can bring to the table and
just get value bought and if people
don't take you seriously people think
what do you know you're just a kid then
screw them screw them you know what does
it matter
it really doesn't matter so also I think
that when you think people are not gonna
take me seriously then people will kind
of sniff that out like how a dog sniffs
out fear so just be confident if you're
there's nothing more attractive than a
young 19 year old person who's suited
and booted and confident you know
there's nothing more attractive than
then confidence because when you're
confident and when you just and be
honest as well don't try and pretend
that you know everything if someone says
some thinking you don't know what it
means just say you know what I'm
actually learning so what does that mean
or you know someone says something like
are you going to be paying cash or
mortgage and you just say oh I'm
actually sure yet you know I need to
work all that out but I'd love to view
the property and just be calm and and
just don't be worried you know seriously
don't be worried and what most people
think of you is none of your business
you know the average person only has
nine people cry at their funeral nine
people cry at their funeral yeah we
worry so much what other people think
when there's only really gonna be nine
people at a funeral crying everybody
else will either not be there or be
there out of just Wow I suppose I want
to guard so why you so bothered about
what they think so for my young people
just relax
be confident don't try and pretend you
know everything
and don't be afraid to say I don't know
what that means but get the answers and
whatever for one thing for goodness sake
don't keep telling me or anyone about
your age now get people posting
questions so I'm a 19 year old blah blah
blah I'm like I don't need any age I
don't need to know your age when someone
says to me oh hi so basically my
situation is I'm 20 years old
straightaway what I think is that's a
disclaimer they're telling me I'm 20
years old it's a disclaimer because they
might now say they want to justify their
lack of results their lack of knowledge
it's a justification disclaimer you
don't need a justification disclaimer
you're not 20 years old
I'm not 28 year-old Samuel Leeds I'm
just Samuel Leeds and you just you so go
kick some ass anyone when you get back
in the hot tub